and uh we'll say hope we're all enjoying
this is our our uh inboxes slowly fill
up with unread
messages but um very nice to have
somebody
talk okay uh thank you um all right so
my goal I guess this the last talk about
uh Quantum a correction is to just draw
some pictures uh I just really want to
get a nice intuition as to what
information theoretic uh Quantum a
correction looks like
um because I think you know there's
actually a lot one can say about error
correction if you just take just an
information thetic perspective so I'm
going to not really think about decoding
or encoding or what those Maps look like
and just try to understand what it means
from just
information so to start off with maybe I
should say what I think classical error
correction looks like and to me it looks
like this fruit called a custard apple
which is um really good fruit uh which
you find in India it's actually
originally from Latin America and it's
got these like there's these little
seeds in it and then each seed is like
covered in this little packet of
Delicious Fruit um and they just like
nicely pack themselves and that's
exactly the drawing that Mary did on the
first SL day right which is that you
just have this picture and what does it
tell you in classical ER correction it
says that okay I have these points and
they all have these balls of some
distance around them and there's no
point within it and that's the picture
and
you know not necessarily efficient to
encode or decode but you certainly have
all the information theoretic
perspective okay so then you might ask
you know what is uh what captures uh
Quantum Eric rection and I didn't know
so what I did is I opened up Neilon
Chang and I tried to see if there's any
diagram that vaguely resembled something
that I could say and here's what I
found end up finding this picture um and
this is what in Neil s Trang they claim
Quantum coding looks like so the top
one's supposed to be a bad code where
the hird space on the left gets sort of
mapped into these hird spaces that sort
of overlap in some weird ways and the
bottom one's supposed to
be um notion of a good code uh which is
correctable but I wasn't exactly
convinced that this was a the right
picture because it seems to miss
something which I think confuses a lot
of people who come from classical error
correction which is that the whole point
was that the errors were supposed to be
continuous the whole point was that in
quantum mechanics everything's moving
around it's not exactly discreet so how
does this picture here capture a notion
of continuous errors and all the
previous talks this week have all just
talked about bit flips and phase flips
and sort of said okay you know that's
sufficient if we talk talk about these
things it makes everything work out and
let's not worry about all the other
types of
errors but maybe what I want to do today
is that what I want to show is I want to
make sense of what this picture comes
how it how it should come to be why it's
probably the right picture for what
Quantum error correction looks like and
moreover um where the continuous errors
sit in this
place okay so with my outline for
today the the primary goal is to explain
the neelon Chang diagram that's what I
want to get to if I get that I'll be
happy then what I'll try to say is maybe
a little bit what are called the canil
ofam conditions which are sort of a
mathematical way of capturing what it
means to be an information theoretic
error correcting code and then we'll go
on and then we might talk about the
complexity of code States and some qltc
stuff but
possibly okay so classically right you
just think of these two to the K
disjoint Hamming balls of radius D on n
buole and hypercube or higher
dimensional space and if you just want
information Theory you don't have to
make any assumption on the structure um
but if you don't make any assumption
then you don't get any decodability and
that's about the entire picture in the
classical setting which is you just have
these
things right and your encoding map is
just a bje from this from K bit strings
to the centers and if you have an error
you just don't really leave the ball
because you're just finite distance
away from the center so decodability is
possible just triv so what's the quantum
analog well like I said previously um
you know you have these discret errors
classically but you need to deal with
continuous
errors okay so in order to do this I
need to sort of come up with a way of
drawing High dimensional space that is
that has enough details that we actually
can say what we want to say about error
correcting codes and so this is my
picture um this is It's inspired by the
one from Neilon trong so here's my idea
is these are each of these vectors for
those of you are not familiar with the
quantum notation each of these vectors
are uh
oops uh these are all going to be
orthogonal vectors and they're all just
going to be a basis so this is actually
a uh tensor product space right and
that's why it's sort of drawn as a cube
so this is a direct product space and
these are the vectors in it so um
there's some implicit origin which is
kind of drawn and there's 90° angles
here so whenever you see uh Corners
drawn in a cube like this that's to
represent orthogonal vectors um and then
any Vector in the middle not necessarily
orthogonal with the
others so that's going to be like a
hbert space of three cubits eight
dimensional hird
space okay if you can draw the direct
product you need to be able to draw a
direct sum and the way I'm going to draw
a direct sum is there're just going to
be two objects which are disconnected so
if I see two points these are two
vectors um this angle will always be 90°
so this is a high dimensional space so
this is really drawing a 16 dimensional
space here okay so far so good okay so
now to correcting errors what should
that look like so the goal is we're
going to try to get to this picture that
we had in Neilon trong and here's what
we're going to do first we're first
going to talk about just correcting uh a
finite set of unitary errors so that
means each of the errors is just a
unitary transformation of whatever state
came in and I'm just going to call those
E1 through
EJ that's for now and then once we deal
with that we'll show uh what all that
leads
to and the goal our goal today is that
we want to get to a point where we sort
of see this perspective that we have
orthogonal spaces per
air any questions so far yeah cubes are
in like you fix a basis and then all all
these are encoding for that basis is it
the right thing how to say uh encoding
for the basis no no no I'm just drawing
a Hilbert space so this so This drawing
here is a Hilbert space which is a 16 by
six uh it's a 16 dimensional Hilbert
space and I've identified this is a
direct sum so this this tells you the
bottom eight vectors that one tells you
the top eight vectors and then there's
the direct product structure on the
previous slide yeah so that's also um
that's eight dimensional then here
trying to emphasize their orthogonal
yeah yeah I just want to draw their
orthogonal and that I'm acknowledging
this tensor product
structure yeah this analogy for unitary
errors also work for non-un unitary
errors or we'll get all the way there
great we're building up the whole point
is to get to a nice picture of what all
error correction looks like through
simple drawings um so yeah we're going
to start with the finite set of unary
errors that we want to correct against
and then we'll see what all that buys us
and what's going to the the spoiler is
that we're going to show that if we can
do something about just a few finite
errors then we actually get a large
continuous set and channels all that for
free it all just sort of um comes from
the same
assumptions
yeah strling this um the are are
vectors every every Point's a vector so
if I draw a vector um that looks like
this
yeah sure it's it's just to draw this
like a three Cubit space that that
probably won't come up with any serious
importance but just you can notice that
the bottom side of this Cube all the
vectors have their uh first coordinate
being zero so they're like that's the K
zero and then if you flip to the top
that's the K one should I should I think
of these that you're veres as always
being a standard basis element or not
sure yeah you could think of this as
like what we're going to get to in this
drawing is I can think of this as my
original K Cubit space that I want to
encode so it's the
initial all basis
stand right so the coding map has to be
unitary in Quantum error correction so
all transformations in quantum mechanics
are unitary so the encoding map is what
I'm going to draw here in the middle
which is going to take my uh blue square
to the other Center Blue Square it's
like the ideal encoding but that itself
has to also still stay uh a k Cubit
Subspace a two to the K dimensional
Hilbert space so that's what that
encoding Maps looks like and then we're
going to try to see that with different
errors it's going to move to like a
direct sum with the original
space that's the that's the perspective
we want to get to but how to get to this
direct sum structure is not going to be
initially clear we'll we'll build up to
it okay any other
questions okay
awesome all right so here's where we're
going to get to
hopefully let's start with a simple
example of a non-code so this is very
similar to the picture in Neilon Chang
where the some of the cubes overlap so
why would this
overlap be a problem well you could see
that like if this was the encoding so we
have an isometry that Maps the original
blue cube under E1 time encoding which
takes me over to this guy right and I
have another isometry which takes me E2
encoding over here then you immediately
have a problem because both the orange
vector and the red Vector in the initial
encoding are being mapped to the same
point right or mathematically that's
just saying if I take my encoding and
then I apply the error E1 and I do it
again with E2 I get the exact same point
so if if I happen to show up with this
if this Vector happened to show up I
could not know how to decode it so so
this is a non-code this cannot happen if
you're going to be an error correcting
code but in fact there's actually going
to be a stronger statement which is that
if my initial assumption is that the red
and uh orange vectors were not only um
distinct but they were
orthogonal then I
claim that uh we should actually see
some or ality that occurs so here's what
the picture should look like which is
that if I have two vectors here uh in
the initial thing orange and red which
I'm going to assert are
orthogonal then I claim that in the two
different
encodings the where the red Vector Maps
here and where the orange Vector Maps
here have to be
orthogonal and this is because of what
it means to be perfectly distinguishable
in quantum mechanics two vectors or two
states are perfectly distinguishable if
and only if they're orthogonal so if
they're orthogonal then there exists
some way of distinguishing the states
and if they're not orthogonal then the
best you're going to do relates to the
cosine of the angle between the two of
them
um okay so what does that tell you so it
says you're only correcting these errors
if you can distinguish uh these two
things perfectly and you get the
orthogonality but let's note that it
would be too much for us to ask uh for
orthogonality between these two states
between E1 time applied to the encoding
of one vector and E2 applied on the same
Vector right and the reason is because
if those errors were basically the same
you know they're two unitaries E1 E2 but
they're just off by a minuscule amount
then by linearity of all the
Transformations uh the the angle is
going to be preserved right so you're
not going to be able to get that to
correct but what we'll find is actually
for some errors E1
E2 uh this could be orthogonal so we
sort of see that if there's some notion
of distance between E1 and E2 then we're
going to see that the encodings have to
also have that error excuse me have that
same distance but you know if there's
some encoding which is sort of some
notion of far or orthogonal between two
errors then we might be able to get
orthogonality and what we're going to
see later on is that these errors under
which they are orthogonal sort of form a
basis for the set of Errors you can
correct okay
questions all right okay so what's the
benefit of this orthogonality well
here's what you get right so you have
these two vectors this orange and red
Vector in the initial thing and we're
going to assume they're
orthogonal and then what you'll get
though is that the orange Vector is
going to be orthogonal to all the
different possible encodings of the red
Vector including the one in the error
that it occurred so this orange Vector
um so this is the E2 encoding right so I
have this orange Vector it's going to be
orthogonal to the red Vector because
this was an isometry that took they were
originally orthogonal so they'll stay
orthogonal and then in every other
possible encoding by the previous
argument they'll still be
orthogonal right so what do you get you
have that this orange Vector is
orthogonal to this red Vector so then
you can say something even stronger
which is that if the two vectors were
orthogonal then the spans of all the
possible in Cs and the spans of all the
possible encodings the other side are
also orthogonal which is intuitively
going to get us to this idea that if you
can correct against the errors E1
through EJ then you're also correcting
against the all the unitary errors that
are contained in their span so now we're
starting to see that there's some notion
of a basis for the set of Errors even
though you have a continuous set of
errors in some sense being able to
correct against just some finite set of
them really is capturing everything you
need and so then we're going to start to
see that it's going to suffice to prove
that the error correction properties uh
you only really need them for a
basis and the rest will
follow
questions and this is you know this why
the previous talks really only discussed
correcting bit flips and phase flip
errors and this is because the set of uh
all unitaries can be expressed in terms
of bit flips and face flips like some
linear combination of them and so if you
can correct the bit flips and the face
flips then you can sort of get to
correcting all the
errors yeah said
e errors I assumed it by assumption oh
um that we use that uh for the linearity
statements every now and then right so
whenever I said that uh distances didn't
change too much I was not only assuming
linearity but I was also assuming
unitarity which means that the vector
didn't suddenly get longer or shorter
right they just preserve their
norms and moreover preserve
angles so the unit the unitarity was
necessary here just just to initially
prove that this orange and red Vector in
the initial statement in this E2 times
encoding maintain the
orthogonality right because the encoding
map okay that was uh unitary we're fine
with that but unless I assume the error
is also unary here how am I going to ERT
this angle stays right
angle so we needed
there okay
others sorry what the relationship
between all thees sorry relationship
between only orange I guess when say one
orange and one red are to each other how
about the orang and C
cop oh yeah I mean you can make the same
argument the other way right I'm just
saying that since this orange Vector is
orthogonal to the red Vector in the
initial space it this orange Vector is
orthogonal to every red Vector here
respect one another oh um we we can't
say right for the same argument that we
just did right here where that if you
have two vectors just any two vectors
right they they could be
close yeah this yeah the red and orange
points they're not special they're just
two any two points I just need them for
drawing
next
okay so to be clear uh two orange
vertices could be the same Vector
when no we'll actually show that if they
are if they ma the same thing then the
those two erors were identical at least
acting on that
Vector
okay so what you can actually go and do
a little bit for and I'll leave this as
an exercise is you want to say that that
we actually can sort of get a basis for
the set of Errors which is this idea
that if I have um two errors which I'll
call E1 and E2 now um and I say this red
Vector gets mapped over here and then
the under E1 and then under E2 it gets
mapped over here and then I sort of have
this angle here between the two
encodings between A1 and A2 and then
what you can show is that whatever this
inner product between A1 and A2 is so
this complex number which I'll call
uh I should called it at a one two um
and this you can actually show is that
it's going to be an invariant that only
depends on the errors themselves and not
which state so no matter which state you
started off with in the initial Cube if
you were able to correct the errors then
this angle must have stayed the same
that's the
exercise the hint is you just need to
use the unitarity
property okay so then why why is this
going to give you a notion of a basis
for the set of Errors well if you can
correct all the errors in some uh curly
set e you could just first think about
let me take any Vector a and let me
think of what the span under all the
errors would be of e applied to encoding
of a and that's going to be a vector
space a basis space and if it's a vector
space then there's a basis for it this
we're all just dealing with finite
dimensional Vector spaces here
so then I can find a basis for that and
all those basis vectors were of the form
some
encoding uh some error apply to encoding
so then I'm going to get this E1 EJ
right so I have that these oh whoops um
I have that these E1 through EJ
necessarily exist at least for the
vector a okay but um what you can show
is by by the exercise that if you did
this for any other Vector B same thing
occurs right those same E1 through EJ
have to form the basis so that's also
not exactly obvious but it's not too
hard of a linear algebraic statement of
argue and then this just gives you a
natural notion of a basis of
Errors because you could Define now uh
an inner product on these errors which
is the E1 EJ the inner product between
them is just going to be whatever that
ETA coefficient was which way to look at
it is you could take any a and just
think about what this calculation is and
it's going to be the same calculation
every time and you you'll get a notion
of or inner product between the
vectors and so the basis for the set of
errors that we want this is going to be
a basis with respect to this inner
product okay so so that tells you sort
of there's basis for the errors but now
what happens with those errors that sort
of are you know somewhere in between the
basis vectors well let's take two errors
E1 e and E2 which are going to be
orthogonal so that's I'm just insisting
that because I'm going to say that the
encodings of some Vector this red Vector
are orthogonal and now let's consider
this sort of pink ve uh error that could
occur that's somewhere in between the
two right so we know how to correct if
we were in both of these direct sum
spaces but what do we do in the middle
um so yeah in reality I probably should
have drawn this so this pink one sort of
overlapped both of the purple that I
thought it would get really
messy and so but the idea is that
because um because the two purple
vectors are uh purple errors are
orthogonal because these two are
orthogonal um they form a basis for the
set of errors and we could measure
against that basis right they're
perfectly distinguishable so what we'll
do is that if we actually had this pink
error State and we measure it according
to that basis the error would collapse
to either the one or the other and it
collapses proportional to the angle so
if the angle is Theta it's going to
collapse to the top one with sin squ
Theta and collapses to the bottom one
with cosine
Square so we get this nice thing that
you know if you can correct these errors
is actually something there's a way to
correct all the errors in the continuous
space just by first measuring
which
um you know which gives you this
decoding procedure for the continuous
space of errors from the decoding
procedure for the basis which is a prior
sort of strange and I think this
highlights a strange phenomenon in error
correction that is not too often uh
recognized which is that the way you
sort of do a generalized airor
correction procedure in the information
theoretic world is you measure the
syndrome which means is equivalent to
just collapsing that continuous error to
a basis error the syndrome is just the
name of whatever basis element you got
and then you correct the error based on
the syndrome so error correction is uh
it composes of two parts where the first
one is non-unitary and therefore
destructive it you actually lose the
information and the step two is the
information preserving step it's the
unitary step but in some sense that
should be make sense because you know
you sort of have get the information you
started off with and then you had all
this ex accidental extra information you
acred because of the error it just you
know piled on and by doing this
destructive measurement you deleted all
that and you got back to only the
information that you really wanted which
is the original information you had
encoded so it's in some sense the error
correction you could think of it as some
controll destructive
process okay so that that so that should
uh get you to the perspective where if
you can take these errors that are basis
elements they have that orthogonality
condition we suggested then you actually
get a direct sum decomposition of the
space you're going to get that whatever
my original encoding was if I apply that
error E1 it's going to yield a an exact
copy of the original space and it's
going to be in direct sum the next one's
going to be in direct sum as well and
you get a decomposition of your entire
space uh in terms of
this and then there's a question about
correcting channels you can always
correct an error Channel whose elements
are parts of this because they're just a
probabilistic mixture of uh the unitary
channels
so are there any other
questions yeah so uh you know a lot of
physical errors I imagine something like
decoherence where you know your Cube
becomes a sort of squashed Cube where
you lose distinguishability somehow that
won't fit into this setup right ah so
yeah you it will um because the
coherence you could sort of think about
as a linear combination it's not a
unitary transformation right so then you
have to sort of first break it up into
its unitary components so we'll get to
that in a second when I describe how to
think about eras your errors from this
perspective which is sort of be a
generalization of some
de other
questions um so okay so what's our
picture so classically we had that all
the words that correct to a or sort of
the ball around a and then quantumly
what you have is that it's a Subspace
spanned by that Vector anything in here
there's some error that you can correct
because we said you can always correct
errors if they're linear combinations of
the errors you already knew and it's
this entire Subspace so that's the same
analogy of the ball so that's maybe how
you see the quantum
picture Okay um but this getes you
something very exciting which is it gets
you to sort of a mathematical definition
of being able to correct errors and
that's what we're called the canil llam
conditions and what they are is that
they mathematically capture just all
those orthogonality conditions that we
drew in the previous cartoons so the
idea here is that to describe it you say
that if I have a Quantum Code it's the
image of the encoding map so it's just
the blue square on the on the right hand
side that we previously had and you
think of the projector onto the code as
just some Matrix
pi and then what you can say is that the
code corrects against errors
EI if um this equation holds if Pi
applied to EI dagger E1 dagger E2 Pi is
equal to the the coefficients we
actually extracted out previously the
inner products between the errors and
why is this the case well you can show
that this is not it's not too hard to
show that this is equivalent to the
following statement that any two vectors
I had in my initial space A and B if I
look at the inner product post errors
of those
vectors that's going to be the equation
on the left right because this here this
is the encoding of B and this is the
error EJ applied to that state and then
the other side is the same thing except
the error EI is applied to the state a
well what I should get is that it's just
the inner product initially whatever the
inner product was in the original space
times the inner product between the
errors and um to for you can formalize
this and you can try to if you want to
read what exact recovery operator is you
can read the neon the version of Neilon
Chang but I really think that like just
the pictorial argument is entirely
captures this notion okay so what my
claim is that this equation here is
actually super powerful and it captures
everything you want to say information
theoretically about error
correction we're going to notice some
nice properties that come now that we've
derived that this equation must be true
so so far we haven't even talked about
any instantiation of a code we've just
said that if you can correct against a
certain set of Errors E1 uh EI then you
must satisfy this equation and and and
we sort of said it's necessary and
sufficient although we didn't really
work out all the
details okay so now let's sort of put a
little structure on what those errors EI
might be and um let's just say you want
to correct against all the errors of
size d what does that mean it means that
the error you can think of as some
unitary that acts on just of the cubits
tensor identity on the rest of the N
minus D cubits um and the the punchline
here is that if you wanted to correct
all the errors of size d this is
equivalent to correcting all the PO
errors that are possible of size d and
it's equivalent to even correcting just
the bit flips and phase flips although I
always forget if there's like a d versus
D over2 adjustment that needs to be made
but something like that okay
um what's not so trivial is that it's
equivalent to also correcting all the
Eraser errors of size D um so what is an
eraser
error uh one way to think about an
eraser error in the quantum mechanical
world is that it's the product of an
information destroying channel so you
apply this channel which completely
destroys the information and just
replaces it with the maximum mixed state
and the information destroying Channel
um can be expressed as a linear
combination of poly channels um and so
this error is contained in the span of
the poy errors so if you can correct
against the poy errors you have to be
able to correct against the
um uh information destroying Channel
because it's just a probabilistic
combination of the PO errors so you can
figure out which po error occurred
correct it
okay so this yields you to this property
that correcting D siiz errors is
equivalent to correcting dcbid
erasers
and so this gets you to I think the
first point which is worth uh
differentiating Quantum codes and
classical codes which is that
information in Quantum codes is not
encoded locally uh because locally if
you if there was information contained
um it's going to violate the no cloning
theorem so we'll see that in a
second um but what it says is that if
you look at a Quantum Code and you just
look at a few of the cubits you'll never
know which Quantum state was being
encoded uh and if I don't say this in a
future slide I'll just say it right now
which is that this is not a property of
classical error correction like think of
the repetition code where you encode the
value zero in and zeros and the value
one and n1's any one bit you look at of
the encoded State tells you which code
which word was encoded but that won't be
the case here in fact whatever Quantum
Code has you won't find information
locally yeah
uh just I guess just as a clarification
I think nowadays people always when they
say eraser they also mean you know the
location yeah so if I have like
information destroying but I don't know
the
location um the number of Errors I can
correct is much less than if I know the
location that's true I'm just going to
say that if you can correct the Poes
generically of size d that are anywhere
the PO errors could have occurred
anywhere then you can also correct the
information uh destroying Channel even
if you didn't know where the error
occurred that I agree with but I'm just
saying that uh lately there's been a lot
of work showing that if they are rers
you can actually correct errors up to
way more right sure sure
yeah that's probably true yeah
definitely true
um okay
and how would you prove this
well um
imagine there was an error
E uh um sorry excuse me imagine the
first dbits of the encoding of X1 and
the first dbits of the encoding of X2 so
those are I'm going to call those States
s One S two let's imagine those states
were distinguishable okay so if they're
distinguishable there's some Matrix and
they're D distinguishable means there's
a distinguisher which acts only in the
first dbits what does that mean it means
that mathematically there was unary e of
the tensor product structure e Prime
tensor identity on the rest so that e
distinguish the two of them meaning that
these um these expectations were
different okay but those expectations
can't be different
because um SII is an element of the code
so I can always toss in a projector onto
the code for free and that's not going
to change anything um but then this
right here this is just the canal theam
condition
and I'm going to get that the value is
at a e and it doesn't depend on which
state
s so I exactly get that um the reduced
density matrices on D cubits are exactly
the
same a second proof that's probably uh
maybe a little bit more intuitive comes
from the no cloning
theorem um which is uh you want to sort
of say that uh if I had an encoding map
that looked like this so here's I'm
going to draw it now I have two cubits I
encode them in all these cubits and
here's a desized
region uh imagine I just applied the
recovery map on the orange region so I'm
I'm able to recover it right because
it's a correctable error I get back to
the original state that I started off
with but um if I just let this guy stay
there I just get the original state so
then I get that if this if whatever was
resulting in this state depended on the
original state then the total
transformation was either
nonlinear uh sorry it is nonlinear and
therefore violates the no
cloning um so this property uh that
within the code space that you cannot
distinguish locally is well known as
local indistinguishability um and it's a
very powerful property
um because we'll show that it actually
proves that the quantum States
themselves in the error correcting code
have to be complex have to be have
complex
entanglement okay um I think I said this
for the repetition code just a second
ago but another code classically where
you can do much more is the hadamard
code um where you any bit of
information about the code can be
extracted from two bits of the code word
so if you had encoded the state X and
you wanted to know a.x for example then
you could just pick a random other point
B and just look at b.x plus a plus b.x
those two sites and extract value so
information there is not only uh locally
encoded but it's sort of encoded in
multiplicity right there's many
different ways to extract out the same
information that you want from points
that is not also not going to be the
case in the quantum setting because of
the no cloning theorem so local
information cannot be encoded in such a
way and therefore information is sort of
held in the sort of global properties of
the
entanglement okay maybe a few other
past just correcting errors is you
immediately can get some notion of
cryptography or secret sharing just
because of the fact that information
isn't held locally so if you encoded a
state into n cubits via some code and
you divide it into M pieces um where the
pieces were small
enough uh that they were far less than
the size of the distance then the number
of pieces you'll need is kind of large
uh to recover the
state
um okay and then what we'll say now is
this entanglement complexity which is to
prove that their states which require a
large circuit depth to generate
questions local disting
ability than error
correction uh
yes um so the the cat state which is the
superposition of all zeros and all ones
so it's just C all superposition of all
zeros plus all ones with like one over
root2 Factor if you took that cat state
but you also had a bit had a phase so
it's all zeros minus all ones you'll get
that these two states are locally
indistinguishable up to size n minus one
but they don't form an error correcting
code local and distinguish is not just a
Quantum property like classically
distributions can have local and
distinguishability as well so if you
look at the distribution over binary
strings of even Hamming weight and the
uh distribution over binary strings of
odd Hamming weight they're also locally
indistinguishable because any reduced
region just looks like
noise um so there's a classical analog
to this idea that um states have
complexity which is that the uniform
distribution over a good code and I
won't exactly specify what good means
and all the possible uh image
distributions of ac0 circuit so short
quantum circuits of arbitrary fanin
these are statistically very far apart
so you could never have generated the
uniform distribution over a code um via
a short ac0 circuit and this actually is
a stronger statement than the encoding
depth of that circuit of any classical
code because if you could
encode uh in short depth then you can
also generate the uniform distribution
just by pushing through Randomness
through an encoding circuit so it's a
slightly stronger
statement
um so quantumly we're just going to
prove that every code State uh which is
the output of the encoding circuit
requires depth at least log D where D is
the distance of the code to
generate um and key key difference is
that classically you can talk about ac0
fanin circuits because they have
unbounded fanin is well defined with
classical information just Quantum lead
that doesn't really exactly make sense
so we're just going to talk about
circuits of bounded Fanon like depth 2
and the classical intuition comes from
what you call noise sensitivity which is
that short depth
circuits uh have the property that if
you take a value X and you take a little
noise the probability that the function
switches values for a Boolean function
with one output is actually pretty small
but what's the problem is with codes is
if I if imagine F was sort of a subp
part of my encoding circuit well it's
going to have the property that if I
take two values which are different and
I encoded they have to move very far
apart they have to move like distance D
apart right so most of the coordinates
have to change um and that's just not
going to happen due to noise sensitivity
unless the depth is
large the quantum proof I'd argue is
also just simpler and it comes from the
following
idea um which is if the state uh
encoding of a had depth T so if there
was any state that was in the Quantum
Code which had low
depth um P then you could distinguish
that state from some other state B which
is orthogonal in depth t+
one so being able to construct the
state is necessarily harder than the
distinguishing problem and why is that
the case well you could just run the
circuit in Reverse so if you ran on
reverse on a right you just get You'
take the encoding of a and you'd undo
the encoding so You' get all
zeros and if you did it on B you're
going to get this state but linearity
says that if if a and b were initially
orthogonal then this vector and this
Vector are also orthogonal which means
that you must have this orthogonality
here so there's some Cubit which could
be measured to prove the orthog to to
show that they're
orthogonal they can't be perfectly
distinguishable S I can ask a question
so so you're assuming that t is larger
than the uh size of the um the cubits
right like I I need to take and deps to
measure all cubits or it's actually
worse than that because I need to like
run this repeatedly no no no I'm just
saying there must be some Cubit right
consider any this you're not worried
about the complexity of that task right
in practice it still could be very hard
to distinguish this from sure I'm just
saying that if you could distinguish in
depth T then there is a way to
distinguish in depth t plus one because
think about this Vector if this Vector
here is orthogonal to the all zeros it
must have it's it's entirely supported
on vectors of Hamming weight one or
bigger right so there's some C at least
one of the
cubits has a measurement probability is
non
zero right okay I I just it's not
obvious to me how I should think of that
as a depth one circuit because I could
that probability could be arbitrarily
small right it's like one over n or
something it is but we're just talking
about perfect distinguishability so
that's okay and we're not this is not
about uniform circus this about
non-uniform
any other
questions so so from this result that
you know if you have these encoding
states of low depth then distinguishing
takes just one more depth it says that
if you wanted to prove you know the
encoding states have uh large depth then
it satisfies to show that there's no way
of distinguishing in depth less than log
D and to do that all you need is this
local and distinguishability argument
because if there was a depth T
distinguishing Circuit look kind of like
this right you know you take in a state
over here you apply the depth T circuit
then you measure and you distinguish
then you look at the back like cone of
that state and it's going to imply that
there was an observable of size 2 to the
T that could have been measured on the
initial state but that says that the
information to distinguish the state was
of size two to the T and so as long as 2
to the t is less than d That's
Impossible gives you the lower
bound
um it's crucial that to say that all the
arguments we've made so far have assumed
nothing about the structure of the code
other than the fact that it uh has
distance D and at subtle points we
assumed that it encodes at least one
cubit um but other than that we didn't
make any other assumptions about the
code nothing about it being CSS or any
structure these are just the properties
that are inherent in Quantum error
correction
um uh so if you want to say more if you
want to understand how to talk about
approximate code States or low energy
states of the code you're going to have
to do slightly more you're going to have
to start making some assumptions about
uh the structure of the code
um which will be inherently necessary
because of you know um our arguments
really strongly relied on perfect uh
distinguish
ability
questions so one one way you could do
this is a theorem that I proved with
anagan and Niko Brookman which said that
for all good codes of energy uh low with
respect to the code hamiltonian they
require log depth circuits but crucially
in order to get there we had to sort of
understand the notion of good codes and
we had to look at specific structured
CSS stabilizer codes in order to get
that um it's I I don't know how to make
this sort of statement for a generic
family of codes without assuming a
considerable amount of structure of the
code um but with that maybe it's also
worth saying a little bit about what the
picture for CSS codes are because
although the picture for generic
information theoretic codes is nice it
might also be a value to sort of
understand the very specific case that
we think so heavily about
and you know at first glance you might
think of it as like you just have the
same picture of the two custard apples
just one for the two codes right because
the class because the CSS codes are
defined in terms of two classical codes
CX and
CZ um but I argue and I spent a lot of
time trying to come up with the right
fruit analogy for this is that the right
fruit is actually a
Blackberry um and the reason a
Blackberry is is because it's the only
fruit actually where the what are called
drupelets which are the little sections
of a Blackberry have multiple seeds
um like raspberries and salmon berries
and all the other berries each of these
things only have one seed in them but
blackberries are the only fruit with
like multiple of them and the multiple
thing is key because if you look at the
classical codes that you need uh to form
CSS codes they look a little bit like
this they're these balls but within each
of the balls there's actually tons of
little code words and I think Nico's
talk stressed this that you have to have
all these little code words
that are very close to each other the
actual distance of the codes CX and CZ
by themselves the classical codes is
terrible it's a constant but you need
that in order to get the Quantum Code
this actually necessary why is this
necessary it's because the the drupelets
that form in the code are related by
adding the CZ per code so there's a p
this is the picture of CX but there's an
identical picture going on for the CZ
code and each of those points is related
by adding that code and because you
needed this like uh HX HZ per is equal
to zero for the CSS code condition if
you're talking about the quantum ldpc
codes you must get that the distance
between elements within this drupelet is
constant so you actually have that you
have these like little many many code
words that are occurring but then the
fun part is while there are lots of
these points that are short distance
from one another they form these natural
drupelets which have this distance from
one another so maybe this is the for CSS
codes they really look like blackberries
and I don't think there's any other
fruit or object with this kind of
property but there's actually even more
structure because if you take a Quantum
Code State for the CSS code and you
measure that code state in the X basis
you will get an outcome which is a code
word so the measurement if you measured
every cub in the standard basis it's
going to give you a bit string and that
bit string has to be one of those code
words
the same is actually going to follow if
you did the CZ code but you have to make
the Z measurement right okay and
secondly there these logical bit
measurements if you measure the logical
bits of the code they form these
separating hyperplanes that divide half
the duplets on one side and half them on
the other side um and what you're going
to see is that this lets you use a very
nice uncertainty principle of quantum
mechanics which is you can take the
logical bit flip and the phase flip for
the first Cubit of the code the nice
thing about CSS codes is that logical
bit flip is just a tensor product of the
X Matrix on some of the cubits and the
phase flip is the tenor product of Z on
some of the cubits and if you consider
those two matrices they have to
anticommute because they're The Logical
operators for that first Cubit and so
they have this uncertainty principle
which lets you tell that the variance of
the two measurements if you measure it
according to that operator the variance
of the measurements is at least one the
sum of the variances
which tells you that in one of these two
pictures if you were to make either the
X measurement or the Z measurement
you're going to get some sort of
uncertainty principle that some fraction
of the time the measurement has to be on
this side of the picture and some
fraction of the time it has to be on the
other side the friction picture the
measurement is not dominated on one side
or the other and you can't really say
whether that occurs for the X
measurement or the Z measurement but you
can say existentially that one of those
two measurements has this uncertainty
principle
and where is that coming from well it
actually comes from the fact that this
argument Works no matter which code
State you're arguing about for a
specific code State you can actually
always figure out whether it's the X
measurement or the Z measurement or both
that will be uncertain but if you
generically told me I have a code State
I can't say which of those two
measurements will be uncertain this lets
you this very nice property which lets
you argue about uh the robust complexity
needed to prove
nlts okay maybe maybe I should take
another second take any questions before
we go and maybe I shouldn't even talk
about
qtc's but if there are too many
questions
questions all right so let's talk a
little bit about Quantum locally
testable codes and sort of what the
picture might look like for that so in
order to talk about Quantum locally
testable codes without assuming anything
about the CSS structure we need to sort
of get to defining a notion of syndrome
for error correction and what we can do
is we can take a basis for the set of
correctable Errors it doesn't have to be
the basis you wanted for CSS codes
because we want to say this for all
codes and you consider a basis so here's
the trivial error here's like all the
different
errors what you uh want to do is if
you're encoding K cubits into n cubits
then there will be a basis for the
errors of size 2 the N minus
K and what you do is you label each of
the different Errors By some bit string
and it can be longer than n minus K you
can give it
a a label with redundancy and that label
is the
syndrome the syndrome sort of delineates
now there are um basy elements of the
bases which on one side versus the other
right and then the weight of the check
the I check will be the definition will
be the minimum operator any operator the
number of cubits that operator Mi Aon
which distinguishes these two bases be
the all the basis elements where the the
value of the I check is zero and all the
basis elements where the syndrome name
is one over here and we know that such
an observable must exist because you
know everything's orthogonal all these
basis elements are orthogonal so it
exists the the art really in qtc's is
Right would be to create operators of
low
weight which tells you that some
syndrome labelings are better than
others and that's really where um you're
going to have to do some work so
question so you check here is is there a
stabilizer um no it's just some
measurement which outputs zero on all
the vectors in the left set and outputs
one on all the vectors in the right side
it it doesn't have to be a stabilizer
stabilizers have equal IG have equal
number of IG values that are plus one
and minus one it could be something more
General the Ste is one of the values
yeah size of the observable Mi is that
just the number of cubits yeah so mi can
be expressed as acting on these cubits
and then tenser identity on the rest of
the
cubits okay so what is a Quantum LTC a
Quantum LTC is that um you'd say a code
is row locally testable if the the
expectation over the observable Mi the
probability that it detects it is at
least row times the distance where the
error E is of size Delta so if you have
the larger your error is the more
detectable it is a random check must
detect it and if you could get row to be
Omega of one that would be
optimal you mean the weight of all these
yeah
yeah um okay so there's some results uh
best known but we don't really have uh
you know we don't know how to create row
equals 1 with also good weight and good
distance um
so uh yeah so there's this there were
these constructions that had constant
soundness uh but the check weights and
the distances were lacking right
so so maybe let me say a little bit
about just why are quantum ltc's hard to
construct um classically you can create
a very simple LTC in five minutes which
is you just take the repetition code and
you add random checks that forms a
locally testable code just for the
repetition code uh because of the
expander properties of a random code and
inherently expansion is sort of crucial
for constructing locally testable codes
classically you have you know you can
think of this expander example or the
hadamard code very high expanding
objects but in Quantum Quantum
mechanically expansion is going to place
a limit on the local testability of a
code um and to to emphasize this result
there's a no there was a proof by aravan
Elder in 2013 that said that if your uh
if your Quantum Code is sort of small
set expanding and it's Epsilon optimal
um I'm going to speak very highly then
it implies the soundness is bounded by
Epsilon so the better you are at
expanding the worse the soundness of
your code is um and this is coming from
this interplay of this local and
distinguishability property no cloning
theorem along with
expansion and it implies there's some
sort if quantum locally testable codes
exist they have to come from some sort
of Goldilocks regime of uh expansion
yeah for these examples of qcs that
you're mentioning is this just for
encoding like a single CIT
or don't remember but it's like we don't
really care about the r it's like even
encoding one Cub it's
already I think
so okay
um so uh sort of the the rough idea of
how that
argument goes that if you know the
expansion is the better the expansion
gets the worse the soundness of the code
goes is the following intuition which is
that for any code classical or Quantum
you can draw this sort of bipartite
graph between the cubits on one side the
physical cubits and the checks you just
draw an edge whenever that check
participates non-trivially on that Cubit
and you have this bipartite graph and uh
you'd say something is a Epsilon small
set expander if the number of check that
use the Cubit uh that use cubits from s
is like roughly the optimal size the
optimal size would be the size of s
times the
degree uh and then you know if you add a
little one minus Epsilon it's like
roughly Epsilon optimal okay the the
problem is that if you have the sort of
optimal
expansion then you get that in sets s
you look at Gamma s there's most of the
points actually have a unique neighbor
on the other side
um and unique neighbors are bad in the
set of in the case of quantum error
correction um because what I'll claim is
that you it lets you construct a large
eror that violates few checks which is
exactly the worst case uh for Quantum
LTC um the idea is that you know uh you
have the the checks of the code they
commute on the code space um let's just
first seconds say they commute
everywhere uh you really only need them
to commute on the codes space but all
the examples of codes we construct so
far they commute
everywhere and if they commute
everywhere and you have a bunch of
checks that only overlap on a single
Cubit uh like so so you have checks I
where these checks they only intersect
on this one cubit then there was this
nice result uh Long Ago by brav and
viali which said that morally that Cubit
is acting classically that Cubit can't
Quantum if these checks if the checks
don't overlap uh in a non-trivial manner
so if checks only overlap on one cubit
then there must have been a classical
way to assign the value of that Cubit so
then you end up with a you just have
these very simple class either you have
classical states which we know can't
exist for error correcting codes by the
local and distinguishability argument or
you have that you have terrible
soundness so it's like this Catch 22
that
occurs
okay um guess how much time do I have
you
know um five minutes five minutes okay
um so let me just say a few large things
I recognize that as we you know get to
the Terminus of this talk it's getting
more and more technical but you could
say like okay well you know you what if
you just imagine that you had qtc's does
that get you anything like just just
from the simple Assumption of their
existence you're able to say all those
things about Quantum ER correction just
from their properties now if you just
assumed qtc's what would that give you
um so where were classical ltc's used
well one one example is they're very
pivotal in the construction of pcps so
you could ask you know is a Quantum
analog the case can you take Quantum
ltcs and you could construct pcps
directly and it's not so clear um and
the reason why you might think that is
well what is the PCB theorem you know if
you're in an elevator and you had to
explain it to someone you might say that
you just take an NP witness like the
solution to a threet formula and you
just wrapped it up in a really really
nice error correcting code with some
locally decodable LTC that you wrapped
it up and it's it's more technical than
that but you know that that would give
someone a pretty high level explanation
of how it works um one example is that
you could just take your solution to
your thre set formula and you could
encode it in the exponentially long PCP
for the hadamard code right um and that
that would work it would be
exponentially long but that's you know
the rough
intuition um what's the problem is that
you couldn't do this same sentence for
Quantum pcps because the quantum codes
can't have good distance and be locally
distinguishable the whole point was that
you wrapped it up in this code and you
protect it against errors and noise and
adversarial noise all in one time but
you also still maintain uh local
decodability which let you extract out
the values if you wanted to do all that
with your Quantum air correcting code
well then locally can't find the values
so it doesn't even seem clear uh how to
create an exponentially long Quantum PCP
even if you had some blackbox Quantum
LTC so even that's sort of wide open um
so what are quantum ltc's good for I'm
not exactly certain um other than they
might be like a fantastic mathematical
object to try to build um it's not
exactly clear if they have a complexity
use directly but trying to come up with
an argument that says if I had a Quantum
LTC and created a and could create a
quantum PCP that also is a very
interesting open task um that we don't
know if it's true or
false um so I'll just say that hopefully
there'll be more to come in some
Workshop uh in the middle of March um
but with that I'll end and take any
[Applause]
questions uh so the explanation longc is
still uh yeah QTC of any uh Cubit to
encoding rate so the rate question yeah
even rate one size n is open so that
would be like an exponentially long
under three
parameterization on that note I mean is
it uh what if your distance what if
you're not going to be good against
constant fraction
much smaller oh like constant size
errors yeah so then there was this
construction
um
uh where was it here this one uh the
either of these two they're both in the
same paper where the soundness was
constant but the checks were constant
but the distance was also constant so
maybe that could be used in some Square
in comes up a lot in these Reas there's
a squared in kind of thing that you
might say you could get squared in
distance dist yeah yeah I don't know too
much about this uh if there have been
any papers that Express this there was
this paper here by larier London zore
where the distance did come out to be
root n um and the checks were even
logarithmic size but the soundness was
only um inverse
logarithmic so this whole um imp
possibility arguments
on uh the locality
since
the uh information theoretic argument uh
so if you
encode K copies of the same state uh
go possibly um but if you think of if
you have K copies of the same Quantum
State then what you'd hope is that you
know I can get the measurement of some
two Cubit observable by taking Cubit one
from copy one and Cubit two from copy
two but that measurement is not going to
give you anything right because those
were
unentangled sort of how to take the
measurement property that you might want
which is cubits One and Two from the
initial copy and now extract that
measurement from multiple copies is not
clear
[Applause]
either all right thank you